my expectations of pit bulls is that
they have scary teeth and they are often
guard dogs
I want to believe that they're nice dogs
I want to be like I want to be doggy
races I'm excited
fish kind of nervous fish this isn't
something that I'm looking forward to
necessarily but I'm gonna do it I mean
I'm not I'm not a dog person so I don't
know what I'm supposed to do here
destroy it feel very brave oh oh you are
cute look at then why don't you smile
you don't look like you're gonna bite my
face off
high-five
yeah good job dog I always imagined them
to be like he's really mean like
drooling with the teeth she's doesn't
move it she didn't attack me I haven't
even seen her teeth and these things are
really soft they're actually smaller
than I thought I thought they were more
I thought they were just like those like
really big muscle dogs but they seem so
tiny oh but I can rub your tongue I'm
being super creepy right now I don't
have any more treats I just have crumbs
on my hands yeah high five what okay
they're good dogs what wouldn't that
would call it to like walk around and
everyone's kind of scare to you I
thought you'd be like way bigger and
like have smaller ears and just like
constantly showing your teeth I like pit
holes or I like these two pickles
they're very sweet and
and I like them every dog is like a
child you just have to raise it the
right way